Just before we get started,
some of you might know that I have another channel called mega-projects,
which is all about mega-projects. If you don't please do subscribe to us well,
by popular demands,
I wanted to cover some things on that channel that weren't quite mega enough for
it. So I present to you a new channel side projects,
covering secret Soviet space, weapons, world war two's, greatest airplanes.
History's lost treasures and the movements of London bridge from London to a
random town in America, stuff like that. New videos,
three times a week on that channel.
So if you're thinking I don't get enough videos from Simon, well, there you go.
Link below. Please do subscribe and let's get into it.
Yes.
He was one of the 20th century's greatest icons.
When Nelson Mandela walked free from prison in 1990, having served 27 years,
he was already world famous.
The ones I'm leader of the armed wing of the African national Congress had been
sentenced to life imprisonment for standing up to South Africa's racist
apartheid regime.
Yet it was while in jail that Mandela had transformed from an inexperienced
Millicent into the man who would bring democracy to his nation first from
his cell. And then as a free man,
he negotiated an end to white minority rule the in franchisement of the black
community and managed to steer South Africa away from a civil war.
By the time he became president in 1994,
his place in history was already assured. But while most of us know Mandela,
statesman, what do we know about Mandela?
The man born into royalty in 1918 Mandela entered a world which despised
him simply for the color of his skin. First as a lawyer,
then as a millisecond Mandela fought to change the world's a battle which would
see him humiliated and incarcerated, but never beaten
From the moment he was born on July the 18th,
1918 Nelson Mandela's parents knew their boy was destined to shake things up.
You can tell from the way they named him, Raleigh [inaudible],
which translates as troublemaker butts,
not even chief Henry mcgartland Mandela could have predicted just how much
trouble his boy would. One day. Cause from the earliest age,
Mandela's life was full of contradictions. On the one hand,
he was a member of the Royal house of the thin blue people on the other.
He didn't exactly live in luxury.
His family slept on straw mats while his mother cooked over a simple hole in the
floor, Mandela himself grew up wearing his father's old hand. Me downs,
as far as duty aged five was to work as a harder,
not exactly the sort of Royal upbringing you see in Disney movies.
Still Mandela did have advantages that many other South Africans lacked from
1925, he was able to attend school.
Then still a luxury among the black community. Whereas teacher bestowed on him,
the English name Nelson, when his father died at the end of the 1920s,
he was adopted by the region of Themba allowing him to go and live in the great
place of [inaudible]. And I'm sorry about the pronunciation on some of these,
uh,
I looked about when I can that only the pronunciation dictionary and later life
Mandela would say it was here, that he learned about leadership.
It was also where he learned to hide his pain.
When he turns 16 Mandela underwent the traditional Rite of passage into manhood,
a ceremony marked by circumcision with a spear.
Although he was.
Prepared for it to Hertz, Mandela was shocked at just how intense the agony was.
It claimed it felt as if I was shooting through my veins. Yeah.
He was also aware that to show his pain would be weakness.
So he raised his head and lets out the cry of Nidia and Dota visibility to mask.
Even the worst agony would become a hallmark of his life. By the late 1930s,
Mandela was continuing his education way beyond what most nonwhites in South
Africa country, mov age 19,
he enrolled in the nation's only college for black students from there.
It was onto university where he excelled at boxing and athletics and began to
dream of joining the civil service.
The highest career a black South African could then rise to sadly,
this dream wouldn't last in 1940 Mandela took part in a student protest against
the poor quality of canteen food rather than negotiate the school summarily
expelled him.
Mandela's guardian was furious telling him that he'd have to submit to an
arranged marriage.
If he wasn't going to study instead of Mandela flat stealing two cows from his
guardian, he sold them and used the proceeds to fleet to Johannesburg there,
he settled into the township of Alexandra cramped, overcrowded slum for blacks.
First, the young man found work as a nightwatchman,
but he was soon fought and left destitute and there his tail might've ended.
It had not met Walter Sisulu.
I real estate agents who was friends with one of Mandela's cousins.
As soon as took the boy under his wing.
He found a job for him as a law firm where Mandela was able to complete a
correspondence course. But for our story today,
the most important thing Mandela got from Sisulu was his friends as hung out
with a whole lot of radicals from black African nationalists to white communists
there.
Do you think that had in common was that they wanted to tear down white minority
rule? It was a fight that was about to get a whole lot more agents.
Okay. So it's time for us to talk about the racist white elephants in the room.
Apartheid. Although past eight efficiently began in 1948,
less official forms of the system have been around almost since South Africa's
1910 formation.
The 1913 land act had begun the process of forcing black Africans to
live on reserves in response to a small number of the black elite forms,
what would become the African national Congress or ANSI to fight back?
Not that they'd have much luck in the years leading up to 1948,
the separation had grown more and more entrenched to the point that black people
could only enter non-black areas for a specific reason,
but baddest things where they were about to get worse on may the 26th,
1948,
the white voting population handed a sweeping win to the African and national
party whose campaign had used the less racist dog whistles and
more racist bull horns.
It was the national party names and implemented a partite, meaning, uh,
partners and Afrikaans,
a system designs to not just separate black from white,
but white from every other race as well.
Sex and marriage between whites and non-whites was outlawed.
And the entire South African population were sorted into the categories. White,
black, or Bantu colored and Asian,
every urban area was then segregated along those lines with only people from
that category allowed to own a business live in or buy a property in the area.
What job you could have, how you were educated.
And even if you were allowed to political representation,
all dependent on the color of your skin.
And this was only the beginning in the mid 1950s to new land acts and did 80% of
all land in South Africa to the white minority at a time when whites made up
barely 20% of the population shortly after the government created 10 scattered
African homelands.
And so began the forcible relocation of all non urban blacks into these Bantu
Stans,
all tolls around 3.5 million people were dumped into these places where they
plunged into extreme poverty. Meanwhile,
that confiscated land was sold to whites at favorable rates. It was in short,
a criminal racist system.
One that became ever more militarized and murderous as time went on.
It was also the system that compelled Nelson Mandela to fight by the time of the
1948 election Mandela had already been a powerful member of the ANCs youth
league for several years.
During that time had radicalized more and more becoming attracted to an ideology
of civil disobedience. At first,
the platform of Mandela's had been ignored by the main ancy,
but then the national party had come to power.
It's the idea of resistance had taken off big time in 1949.
The ANC officially adopted Mandela's program of action transforming itself into
a Mullen's organization.
But while Mandela was already preparing to fight the apartheid regime,
he wasn't yet ready to make alliances to do so. In his early days,
Mandela was a hardcore Africanist.
Although the ANSI wanted to work with local Indian and communist movements,
Mandela refuse to get involved. His efforts led to the ANC,
sitting out to communist organized strike in may of 1950, because of this,
the apartheid regime was able to crack down on the strike as much harder
unleashing a wave of brutality that shocks Mandela to his core in
the aftermath of the carnage Mandela met with his fellow ANSI member Oliver
Tambo who told him today, it is our communist party tomorrow.
It will be our trade unions are Indian Congress.
Then our African national Congress.
It was the beginning of a sea change in Mandela's attitude,
no longer would he take a narrow Africanist view of the struggle against
apartheid from now on he'll take help from wherever you could get.
The further the ANZ moved towards radical action. The higher its ranks,
Mandela Rose eventually becoming deputy.
President's a huge part of it came down to Mandela's ability to organize people.
He was a key player in a 1952 rally where attendees burns their passbooks
kind of internal passport for nonwhites under the regime.
He was also good at building bridges with other organizations,
helping to create the multi-racial Congress Alliance against apartheid.
And he took his activism into his personal life too in 1952 and Mandela and all
of the Tambo opens the country's first black law partnership.
Naturally all this invited attention in December of that year,
Mandela was placed under a travel ban for bidding him from leaving Johannesburg.
It was meant to stymie Mandela's political organizing,
but the Wylie young lawyer just turns to other means helping organize the
rainbow Congress of the people from afar taking place just outside of Joburg.
Mandela could only watch from a distant rooftop.
As the Congress affirms a freedom charter,
which red South Africa belongs to all who live in it, black or white.
It was a powerful, simple statement of trees,
but it was also like waving a red flag that the racist Afrikana bull
Mandela was arrested alongside 155 other members of Congress Alliance and
charged with treason. His trial would drag on for the rest of the decade.
All the while the brutal realities of apartheid only got more brutal.
The pinnacle of all of this may have been the shop film massacre in March,
1960 white police officers unloaded submachine guns into a crowd of black
protesters killing 69, but rather than blame the racist cops,
the government blamed the ANC banded outright yet they still couldn't stop.
Its most famous son from organizing Mandela was eventually acquitted at
histories and trial and vanished undergrounds becoming a semi legendary figure.
Always one step ahead of the police. Although his law firm collapsed,
he still had his contacts and he still had his organizational skills,
but he had something else now to a growing sense of anger.
The more black bodies piled up at the hands of the police,
the more lands were swiped from nonwhites.
The more Mandela became convinced peaceful resistance is not the answer.
A freedom fighter learns the hard way, you know,
to said that it is the oppressor who defines the nature of the struggle and the
oppressed is often left no recourse,
but to use methods that mirror those of the oppressor at a certain points,
one can only fight fire with fire for Mandela.
That certain point came in June of 1961, along with a closed cell of loyalists.
He formed whom console. We sees war the spirit of the nation.
They got hold of guns and they began preparing explosives.
And even now there was a sense that becoming a man of violence wasn't Mandela's
destiny that summer as he lay low on a friend's from Rivonia,
his second wife Winnie brought him a rifle, practicing his aim,
Mandela shot a Sparrow dead only for his friend's five-year-old son to
immediately start shouting at him. Why did you kill the bird?
It's mother will be sad. According to Mandela,
my mood immediately shifted from one of pride to shame.
I felt this small boy had far more humanity than I did. Yes.
Mandela had already chosen this path in December,
1961 spare of the nation set off its first bombs at government installations.
Although the attacks avoided casualties,
they still put Mandela in the crosshairs of intelligence agencies across the
globe. When he abandoned South Africa for eight months in 1962,
it was with scary entities like the CIA watching him.
And that may explain what happened next that August Nelson Mandela returned to
South Africa. Although in disguise, he was arrested by police.
He knew exactly who he was long rumored to have been due to a CIA tip-off that
day, August the fifth, 1962 was the end of Mandela's time as a free man.
When he finally left jail again, 27 long years would have passed.
[Inaudible] originally.
The Mandela wasn't meant to spend anything like three decades behind bars in
1962, all the police could prove was that it left the country illegally.
So he received a mere five years, unfortunately, half a year into his sentence.
The police raided a safe house and discovered a stack of bomb making materials
and to legal documents. All of which could be traced back to Mandela.
The result was the Rivonia trial named after the leafy suburb,
the safe house was found in starting in October of 1963.
It returns Mandela to court alongside other ANC leaders.
The death penalty seemed such a foregone conclusion that Mandela used his last
day and the doctor make a bond storming four hour speech,
which ended with him declaring during my lifetime,
I have dedicated myself to this struggle of the African people.
I have fought against white domination and I have fought against black
domination.
I have cherished the ideal of a democratic and free society in which all persons
live together in harmony and with equal opportunities.
It is an ideal which I hope to live for and to achieve.
But if needs be, it is an ideal for which I am prepared to die,
but die is exactly what Mandela didn't do. Instead.
He was sentenced to life in prison on Robben islands.
It's hard to comprehend nowadays.
Just what a minor figure Mandela was when he went into prison and compared with
who he was when he came out. Sure. He had a big following in South Africa.
I'm sure his travels in 1962 had seen him make connections with important
people,
but he wasn't internationally famous where you do ask someone in mid 1960s,
America who Nelson Mandela was that probably assume you had some weird speech
impediments that prevented you from saying Nelson Rockefeller. Nope.
The reason Mandela became an icon isn't because of his life before Robin Island,
but because of his unjust imprisonment, that however,
that recognition would take decades to accumulate decades in which Mandela lived
a life of numbing TDM in prisons,
alongside other ANZ members in section B Mandela was forced to do backbreaking
later in the midday heat first in a lime quarry, then breaking boulders.
He was allowed to write only a single letter every six months and receive two
visits.
A there was no compassionate leave when both his mother and eldest son passed
away in quick succession, Mandela was refused permission to attend the funerals.
It was a life designed to make the world,
forget you to cut you off from your family and network,
but both Mandela's allies and his enemies conspired to keep his memory alive
wisely.
The ANZ used him as a symbol for all the political prisoners of apartheid giving
the international community, uh, named a natural zoo.
But it was also thanks to the apartheid government who saw his growing
reputation and started making them offers such as freedom in return for
recognizing the controversial black homelands that that established naturally
Mandela refused.
But it's maybe too easy to portray the Mandela story as simply that of a Saint
changing the world from inside his prison cell,
as admirable as Mandela's courage and dignity, where in this period,
he really was just a simple,
it was the people on the ground who were doing the tricky work of bringing down
a partite. Thanks to them.
Mandela would be perfectly positioned when the time came to lead his country to
democracy.
[Inaudible].
The 1970s dragged on South Africa began acting more and more like the
geopolitical equivalent of Cujo. The rabbit dog.
There was the Soweto uprising when police fired tear gas and rubber bullets into
a crowd of schoolchildren injuring 4,000,
that was the repressive crackdown afterwards where 500 black activists were
detained and killed. Then there was the new government formed under PW,
both or in 1978,
although it relaxed the rules on what had been called petty apartheid,
desegregating hotels, allowing interracial marriage.
It also acted increasingly like a military dictatorship.
This is a home where in prisons without charge others abroad were assassinated
by the intelligence services by 1980,
both as governments was engaged in dangerous military,
adventurism all over Africa,
destabilizing its neighbors and meddling and civil Wars.
They even developed their own nuclear arsenal testing a bomb in 1979. Yeah,
none of this posturing could destroy the rot, eating the regime alive.
The rot known as apartheid by 1982,
an international campaign to free all political prisoners in the nation was
gathering steam, known as released Nelson Mandela.
It called for sanctions and a boycott against South Africa until it embraced
democracy. In response,
both at trying to unveil a new constitution that gave the racial categories of
Asian and colored ball rights while still keeping black people oppressed.
But it didn't work. Instead. Community groups forms the United democratic front,
which paralyzed the state with strikes and attacks on the police.
At the same time, the NC began a new phase in its Tara campaign.
Well not authorized by Mandela.
This included the bowling of public buildings come 1985.
The economy was hurting under sanctions and both had imposed a state of
emergency soldiers,
drove armored trucks into black townships rounding up and torturing tens of
thousands,
thousands more when added yet this state repression was unsustainable.
Something even both are realized in 1985,
he made two separate offers to free Mandela asking only that he renounced
violence. Both times Mandela refused it's here,
that we can see some of what made Nelson Mandela. So great.
Although he had now been in prison for over 20 years,
Mandela refused to take the easy route out.
He wants it democracy in South Africa, not just his own freedom.
And he was willing to wait and suffer until both or was ready to deliver it.
But in the end it wouldn't be both. Or you cut the deal in 1986,
the U S followed the UN's example with Congress,
bringing in stinging sanctions against South Africa.
When this was followed by an uproar after Mandela nearly died in prison of
tuberculosis, even the national party,
you could see the writing was on the wall on July the fourth, 1989.
Both came to personally, see Mandela now transferred to house arrest.
When both are refused, the prisoners schools are free.
All of those convicted of political crimes,
he sealed his own fate and months later his own party to post him bringing in
the younger FW to cluck, to Clark,
who is more than capable of seeing which way the winds were blowing.
All that December. The new president held his first meeting with Mandela.
Although their relationship would be frost with Mandela,
never entirely convinced he wasn't just dealing with another racist.
There was enough common grounds between them to open negotiations,
but first Declarc would have to win the ANCs trust. On February. The second,
1990 to clock made a speech freeing all political prisoners in South Africa.
It was so fast that even Mandela was taken aback with almost zero time to
prepare.
It was suddenly released on February the 11th on a day that would go down in
history. Camera crews gathered to film.
One of the world's longest serving political prisoners as he walks out of Victor
Vasta prison and into legend. Although his first words were resounding.
I agreed to you all in the name of peace,
democracy and freedom for all Mandela later revealed just how confused had been
that the attention part of this was to do with changes in technology.
When he first saw a news crew point of boom, Mike asked him,
he thought it was an assassination attempt yet.
Despite the overwhelming sensation of suddenly being both three and a celebrity
Mandela, didn't let it cloud his mind. It was time for the real work to begin
In the multitude of parallel universes out there.
There are a whole ton where South Africa in the early 1990s,
when the way of Yugoslavia with apartheid crumbling,
huge swaths of the population were itching for civil war.
There were white supremacists who wanted to maintain their privilege.
There were black radicals who felt a violin reckoning was the only way forward,
but there were also regional leaders ready to succeed.
Opportunists who saw violence as a way to accumulate money or power in short,
the nation was on the brink.
The only reason it didn't fall into the abyss was due to Nelson Mandela
negotiations to end apartheid began in 1990,
but it was a long and painful process.
Although Mandela was made leader of the ANC,
he couldn't stop political violence. That was gripping his country.
There were massacres assassinations, even as negotiations,
it keeps looking like everything might fall apart.
Like the only way out might be bloody conflict. Yes, Mandela never.
I gave up on a peaceful solution, deepen his heart Mandela.
Sincerely believed a rainbow South Africa was the way forward.
One that existed for all races.
Had he not been so convinced Mandela may have never found the strength to push
on with negotiations,
but Mandela persevered and his perseverance paid off in September of 1993.
The ANC and national party agreed to the date for South Africa's first
democratic election for their efforts Mandela.
And Declarc won the Nobel peace prize,
but it was touch and go until the very last second on April the 27th, 1994,
the ANC won a staggering 62% of the vote in South Africa and the first
post-apartheid election.
And just like that Nelson Mandela became president of the nation that had tried
to destroy him and his inauguration speech Mandela pledge to build a rainbow
nation. He made Dick Clark VP creating a government of national unity.
His biggest breakthrough though came in the immediate aftermath when he
succeeded in drawing white right-wing parties into negotiation. After that,
it was only extremists who continued to insist that the new government was that
legitimate.
The first few years of the Mandela presidency were filled with historic moments.
There was the establishment of the truth and reconciliation commission,
which allows perpetrators of crimes do apply for amnesty and exchange for
confessing while not perfect.
It has since been held up as a model for post-conflict societies,
creating an impartial system that allows families at the debt to discover the
truth. This included truths that were personally embarrassing for Mandela,
as it was revealed that his ex-wife when he masterminded the abductions and
murders of suspected informers.
Another great moments was the unveiling of the new democratic constitution in
1996, forever consigning whites minority rule to the dustbin.
But the most emotional moments likely came in 1995 at the rugby world cup
Mandela, openly supported his nation's team.
The Springboks until only recently a team associated with apartheid rule.
When he presented the trophy to the captain,
it was a national moment of healing, but of course Mandela's presidency.
Wasn't just a listen to your feel-good moments.
He badly misjudged the AIDS crisis. Something had deeply regret later in life.
He also cozied up to some super shady regimes,
openly embracing both Colonel Gaddafi and Robert McGarty by launch late when
Mandela stepped down after a single time in 1999,
it was with a sentence of Trump just nine years earlier,
it walked out of prison into a deeply divided nation on the brink of civil war.
Now he was stepping down as leader of a multiracial democracy that had finally
made peace right itself. Of course, history.
Isn't a fairytale South African presidents placed Mandela or struggles with
corruption and cronyism.
But the fact remains the man and Della himself was a model leader,
a man who continued to do good, even after the presidency,
by working in conflict, mediation and raising awareness of HIV. Sadly,
not even history's greatest leaders can stay around forever. In January,
2011 Mandela was checked into hospital beginnings of a long illness that would
eventually play in his life. Although we plan on for nearly three years,
there was nothing that could be done. Nelson Mandela died on December the fifth,
2013 at the age of 95 with his passing,
the world lost the true hero of the 20th century.
One of the few great leaders who deserved his reputation today,
over half a decade later,
we live in a world that seems to be sliding ever further into division who Wells
in which hatred is the new normal and forgiveness is a sign of weakness.
It's a world in which we need the example of Nelson Mandela,
more urgently than ever here was a man who suffered under his enemies in ways we
can't possibly imagine a man who saw a racist regime, destroy everything.
He helped death. And yet when the time came Mandela, didn't choose to hit back.
He didn't choose the easy path of violence. No,
instead he chose the much harder path of understanding of reconciliation of
healing. It was a tough path to work on fraught with dangerous,
but in the end Mandela did it showing his countrymen that division was not
natural. That war is not inevitable for setting this example.
He remains one of the greatest leaders who ever lived.
So I really hope you found that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below. Don't forget to subscribe.
Thank you for watching.